cool
and we're live
and Russia are you there yeah
and we're live with our audience
okay I can see kalyani is already there
uh hi folks uh so we will be starting
the program view overview session in few
minutes uh on uh discover the impact of
the Celtic EMA ml boot camp on your
journey to success in 2023 uh welcome
everyone so I'm your host Russia Khan
and we already have our speaker with us
Stuart quick and uh he basically will be
taking you through the program over you
of aim boot camp by Caltech so meanwhile
would love to know where you folks are
from so let me just introduce myself on
chart here
so I am from uh India
and my name is Russia
so would like to know where you folks
are from we can just reply on chat here
and uh we can get to know each other
better so uh uh Stuart where are you
from
uh yeah I put it in the chat I'm uh from
the San Francisco Bay Area I live over
across on the uh
on the East Bay Side near Oakland
California
oh awesome I can see folks who are
replying on chat I can see kalyani is
replying I'm from India Gina Johnson is
applying from Chicago and uh is blind
from Texas uh other folks who are
joining in uh just to let you know we're
starting in few minutes uh Meanwhile
we're just introducing ourselves on chat
like where are we from it's always good
to network right uh in these uh Live
Events so yeah would love to know where
you're from I am from India and I can
see a lot of folks are applying
different Arizona Texas L.A and we have
our speaker we're here with us Stuart
who's from the Bay Area
Virginia from Paris France
lovely
uh Arizona Los Angeles
I was just
down in Palm Springs we drove through
Los Angeles on the way to Palm Springs
Irvine San Diego Toronto
great
welcome everybody
Russia I guess we're ready to start now
yes
uh so uh while uh more folks are joining
in just to let you know that we're
starting now uh you can introduce
yourself on chart where you're from uh
so we'll be starting the program
overview uh so we'll be describing the
impact of caltex AIML bootcamp and how
basically can succeed in 2018 through
this boot camp uh we have few ground
rules uh you can put down your questions
in the Q a box here if you have joined
in your laptop you can see the Q a you
know pop up there you can just click on
that and submit your question there uh
and also if you joined from mobile you
can see a similar pop-up of q a you can
just submit your questions there we'll
be taking all the questions so please
don't worry uh in case you are putting
on your questions on chat I'm so sorry
we might miss it because we get a lot of
messages over chat so it's always good
to put another query section so we can
actually answer all of your questions
and the session will be recorded and uh
you can expect a follow-up email with
the recording link and also the bonus
offer which we have for the Caltech EMA
bootcamp
I hope that makes it clear
I can see uh folks are still uh you know
uh like replying where they're from uh
so meanwhile let's get to know each
other better I would love to know how
many years of experience do you
currently have
so yeah are you currently studying are
you uh basically fresher are you started
your journey uh you have zero three two
three years of experience are your mid
professional do you have three to five
years of experience do you have more
than five years of experience you can
just see that question on your screen
they would love to know you better so
how much experience do you have you can
select either of the options uh on your
screen right now and you can just submit
that option so uh I can see uh folks
have already started responding and
people are still introducing themselves
on chat that's great good to have a very
interactive audience today
and I think we can close the poll in
three
two one
it's an interesting result Russia
okay
uh I can see that half of the four
th basically XP experience of more than
five years and a few of them are
currently studying and a few of them
have zero three of his experience and
few of them I have three to five years
of experience as well uh so uh thank you
again everyone for joining for folks how
have they joined now uh we are just
starting over so uh let me take you
through the agenda uh obviously we'll be
talking more about you we'll be getting
to know you better basically what are
you looking uh through this aaml boot
camp by Caltech and answering all your
questions and also be talking about the
eiml careers uh and uh what's a Celtic
boot camp as well we'll be going through
detailed discussion on that as well uh
we'll be sharing learner outcomes and
enrollment steps with you how you can
enroll into the program and also I'll be
taking the Q a questions towards the end
of the program if we get some time in
between uh we'll definitely take some
questions but please don't worry all of
your questions will be answered if you
go and put it in the Q a box
and uh yeah so uh so our speaker today
is Stuart uh Stuart would love to know
uh you know more about you can you give
us your introduction
yeah so this picture is uh back before
my hair turned all gray but um
uh I've had over 30 years of experience
in the technology industry in
a number of different companies number
of different aspects of Industry
um I have an MBA from Harriet watt
University
um I formerly worked for a consulting
firm that also provided enterprise
software for decision support
managing r d and development portfolios
so
um that was some experience to the
concepts of
statistical inference and AI principles
I'm not a AI practitioner but I'm
familiar with the industry and the
application so
speak a little bit towards it some of
you may recognize me as the
a former host of the webinars that
simply learned so we're passing that off
to Russia and she will be your host
going forward for future
editions of the simply learn webinars
but uh
this has been a wonderful experience and
so I'm really very pleased that I can
share this last webinar with you Russia
thank you uh great thank you for the
introduction Stuart and I am actually
privileged you know to getting to do
this last webinar of you as the speaker
I am the host so uh it's really great to
have you here in your last webinar as
well uh and yeah like looking forward to
more such webinars and maybe maybe
someday you can join us and surprise us
you know with our guest appearance
something like that be very pleased to
do that
oh awesome uh so yeah let's take the uh
webinar forward so we'll be talking
about the careers in AI machine learning
today
okay and yeah so this is an interesting
statement um
Ai and machine learning extend human
capabilities
and so this is
Russia you've heard people talk about
how AI is going to take all of our jobs
right
yeah yeah definitely and and that's a
big fear and and really that fear has
been around for
um a hundred years because
word robot actually came from a play
that was written in the 1920s
um
they started thinking about well what
about machines taking over all of our
our work
um intelligent machines that can think
and
do all of all the things a human can
um but if you think about it a little
deeper we've been using machines to
extend our capabilities
um from the very dawn of of human
evolution
a a lever or a spear or a hand ax are
all machines that people use to be able
to do tasks better to throw or cut or
move objects then we developed machines
that were powered by steam or water or
other
Motors and they let us do things like
plow land more efficiently or
move
people more efficiently and so we've
been
inventing machines to help us do things
better for the entire history of
humankind and
Ai and machine learning are very similar
in that
continuing that vein because what we're
talking about are ways to help people do
things
that human beings can't do
um
so we take human capabilities we add
these Technologies and we're able to
accomplish things that no one person
could do so for
specific to Ai and machine learning we
all just come through this pandemic
we all had to learn to
adapt to the remote work or
interacting in a non-contact way with uh
businesses we deal with people we deal
with and so
much of what we've done has gone into
the digital domain faster than ever
before
that means there's much more data about
the world around us and at the same time
developing things like the internet of
things or autonomous vehicles these are
all dealing with much more data than any
human being
um
deal with on their own so if you were to
try to take all of the data about a
corporation sales and make inferences
about what was happening
you would be overwhelmed with the number
of data points managed so you'd have to
um
employ a
hundreds and hundreds of people to try
to deal with the data itself and then
you'd be lost looking for patterns so
the purpose of AI and machine learning
in an environment like that is let the
machine go through and do
that task much more quickly much more
efficiently than human beings can and
then start making
um
insights and and inferences that might
not be obvious to a human Observer
because of the overwhelming amount of
data machine doesn't get overwhelmed in
that sense it doesn't have a cognitive
limit in
terms of all the concepts it can think
of at the same time so it's able to look
for things that aren't obvious
even you know the other end of the
spectrum with AI and machine learning
like an autonomous vehicle
obviously a human being can in fact
drive a car and deal with all of the
necessary data going around although
sometimes we get overwhelmed in that
situation when something jumps out in
front of our vehicle or a tire blows out
and we have to deal with an emergency
but the purpose of AI and machine
learning there is to let the machine
take over things that are boring tasks
things that are routine tasks
but still require some judgment and some
dealing with unexpected situations
so you can't just you know tie a rope to
the steering wheel of your car put a
rock on the accelerator and say that's
a self-driving vehicle the vehicle has
to be able to recognize
as you do what are the the road signs
what are the the turns and twists in the
road
but it also has to go beyond that and
recognize when an unusual situation
happens
child runs into the street or when the
traffic in front of you stops suddenly
so you have to have intelligence there
and this is uh this is what we talk
about when we mean or what we mean when
we talk about uh Ai and machine learning
extend human capabilities
that's pretty interesting uh Stuart
um we're talking about
machine learning which is the ability
for
algorithms to improve
the outputs that they create
based on better data so the
use more data to understand better the
patterns of the real world data they're
getting
um
you can think of it as if you only have
two data points all you can do is draw a
straight line between them
project that the line will continue into
the future
you have multiple data points Beyond Two
you can start looking at different ways
to
decide
how to fit the data to a projection and
so
when you talk about machine learning
it's the ability for the machine to
continually
improve and refine
its algorithms its
choices of inference patterns
to be able to get better results as it
gets more data and learns more
so this is a kind of an exciting
development
um
that
happened over a period of decades but
it's accelerating now to the point where
it's really captured everybody's
attention things like chat GPT and and
generative AI so
do you have any other
questions about that Russia or shall I
go
uh no that that answers uh the question
foreign
what are the career paths uh like people
can follow uh while doing this boot camp
of AIML by karatek what are the career
paths which are open apart from just a
machine learning engineer and AI
engineer uh I can see a lot of career
paths on the screen as well but I would
like to uh you to share some light on
that right
um so
the the
umbrella under which uh artificial
intelligence machine learning follows
data science
um and there's kind of a
artificial intelligence kind of
extends out from data science a little
bit but data science is the the general
area of
looking at
how data models the real world and
how you then can draw inferences from it
make predictions from it
make
prescriptions for what to do in the
future Based on data so
if you start in this direction from the
machine learning standpoint and want to
go deeper into the theory and the
science behind
use of data then you can start from
machine learning learn more get more
experience maybe even take an advanced
degree and become a data scientist
um or you can learn more
get more qualification and learn about
uh
artificial intelligence aspects above
level of machine learning and become an
AI architect became an AI developer some
of that material is covered in the boot
camp and
it
exposure to
Advanced topics
neural networks
generative Ai and that type of thing if
you're more uh Amazon engineering type
of person you're fascinated with how
the data comes in pardon me
excuse me I'm sorry about that um
but if you're more fascinated with you
know how does the system acquire data
how does it get its understanding about
the world
um as represented through data then you
could move into Data engineering become
a data engineer and
deal with that
initial capture or acquisition problem
and then the management problem of you
know what to do with all the data
putting it into
structures and forms that can be used by
the machine Learning System so this
boot camp positions you to become a
practitioner in the field but it also
gives you a kind of a foundation to
pursue different career paths
also just before we move on just wanted
to know that how would you recommend for
someone to get started
uh you know on this career path like
what to choose if they come from a you
know a non-program programming
background or they have some knowledge
of you know our programming background
sure so in this program you do have to
have some knowledge of programming
um but you start off and you learn uh
the techniques of machine learning so
you you would
probably start in your career if this
was boot camp was the initial entry
point for you you would probably start
as a machine learning engineer
um
you would
gain more experience and be able to look
at
the architecture and the
development of more sophisticated AI
systems so you probably would move up in
that direction
and then from there again as I mentioned
if you really wanted to go deeply into
data science and
look at
theory around it more than
keeping your head down on applications
you might go for an advanced degree and
become a data scientist and that way
be responsible for a bigger conceptual
ideas about what Will data tell us in a
given situation sorry about that
um
or as I said you could move into the uh
really Hands-On head down work of data
engineering so you start off at the I
think at that upper left corner and
move
downward or across
but I don't think you can move directly
diagonally unless you're going to enroll
in that
a different type of training for data
science you would start with the
understanding the analytics principles
and then moving to data science from
there
awesome that makes sense
I can see uh like a lot of skills on the
screen right now do firstly read these
many skills they need to be updated
these new skills to become an EIN with
practitioner
yeah uh the first thing is that you know
as a as a branch of data science this is
based on
principles of mathematics and statistics
um for being able to understand patterns
draw inferences
this is uh
level of mathematics that people
generally cover
their lit last years of high school or
maybe
you know early in their college career
um
you do have to have uh we're going to
teach you
of a lot of that but if you have the
basic mathematics skills and kind of
just an understanding of
calculus linear algebra that type of
thing you're you should be able to pick
this up uh
well and then you need to have some idea
of programming um
capabilities because you're going to
start moving into python scripting
language in all the libraries that it
uses for data manipulation for a data
presentation
mathematical functions and statistical
functions so uh you you will get trained
in use of python for for data science
and machine learning
so with that Foundation you can start
looking at How do machine learning
algorithms work
what are the different ways that they're
set up to let a machine learn so you
have a supervised or unsupervised
learning of reinforcement learning
um you have systems where you take
multiple versions of those techniques
and put them together to create better
decisions by applying uh two or more of
them
um you learn how recommendation systems
work
and
then you move on
learn the more advanced topics that take
you into
artificial intelligence principles deep
learning uh kerosene tensorflow are
tools that are python base that allow
you to learn
or allow you to build a neural network
um applications so you learn about
neural networks generative adversarial
networks generative AI
you move into how to
computers understand images imagery
visual cues and you you look to
understand how
computers process natural language and
speech so that they can recognize it but
also as we've seen with uh chat GPT
how to generate
language that
really
simulates human
uh Speech and writing
um so those are the that's the range of
skills
that give you a
solid foundation
um you may not want to
may not need to go through all of the
different Advanced topics
but having
some of that knowledge at that level
gives you an idea of how to
pursue this in the future how to follow
this technology as develops
so
yeah I think that explains it uh so we
have talked about this uh job roles we
have talked about the skills
um I can see that all of you are
interested in actually AIML uh boot camp
and even even getting to know more about
it you know career-wise so what exactly
is stopping you uh you can see a quick
poll on your screen uh where you can see
four options uh where you can see like
what's stopping you from getting
certified in an AML uh so you can see
the first option I can't find a program
with a fully comprehensive career second
one is I wouldn't get the Practical
exposure I need to become job ready and
the third one is I find it difficult to
learn from pre-recorded videos and the
fourth one is my schedule won't allow me
enough time for learning so you can see
all four options on your screen it's a
very quick goal you can just click on an
option which you feel like you know okay
this is always stopping me from you know
get us certified in any animal and uh
yeah you can just uh submit it and so we
will get to know what exactly is
stopping you and how basically we can
help out uh in uh you know getting you
through it
members are still changing a little bit
but uh
stop the poll in about five seconds so
get your answers in hit the submit we'll
stop the poll in five
or three
two
one
hit the submit button please and here is
the result
so I can see half of the folks have said
that I can find the program with the
fully comprehensive curriculum
and I I can see this is like the biggest
uh you know concern like what is exactly
stopping them uh but then I can see like
half of the other folks have said that
my work schedule won't allow me enough
time for learning as well uh and few of
them have said that you know I find it
difficult to learn from pre-recorded
videos and a few of them have said I
wouldn't get the Practical exposure I
need to become you know an AI email
practitioner uh thank you folks for
voting uh so let us take you through the
Caltech program and show you more
details so uh program for Caltech is a
industry learning path uh what happens
in the live learning class uh do they
experience only a live lecture or is it
like much more interactive and they have
lot more to offers to it yeah and we'll
be able to show you
um a brief tour of the learning
environment later that uh
one of our instructors did for us
previously but the the
really great thing about the live
classes it's they're not simply lectures
there are opportunities for you to go
through the course material the concepts
with the live instructor ask questions
get clarity on on your understanding of
the concepts and then the instructor
will take you into the the Virtual Lab
environment that's part of the learning
management system and have you do
exercises
using
Code examples using data sets that will
let you see the practical application of
the concept so that you get to build
lab exercises
with your own two hands basically so
that you can understand what tools are
available how to apply them when to
apply them in which situations
um what you are expecting to get out of
the
um
machine learning exercises that you're
building and the projects you're doing
um so
you are actually learning Hands-On and
in the classroom time classes generally
run we four hours on Saturdays and four
hours on Sundays
and um excuse me
I mean having an allergy
I think I think it's everywhere even
I've gotten it yeah
but um
the the
the class times include this Hands-On
work with the lab environment and then
you have access to that same lab
environment and all the other resources
pre-recorded videos that you can
self-paced learning with and other
resources so that you can prepare for
the following week class you can
complete the court of course projects
that are part of each uh part of the
boot camp so
um
that gives you the flexibility to do
that work in between classes you do the
work on your own schedule whenever you
have the time
it seems like a lot of material to cover
in six months you're only doing it for
you know 10 or 15 hours a week but the
the the experience we have that our
Learners have is
nearly everybody is capable of doing
that and do have to to spend the time in
between
the live lecture sessions but if you
apply yourself and do that
um
this is something that generally can fit
into
um
any working professionals
schedule and
be successful
earned that certificate within six
months so
but do you think it is really possible
to achieve that you know excellence in
eiml to this boot camp in just six
months yeah yeah I mean the curriculum
is comprehensive it does cover uh you
know from the basics on up to the
advanced topics
um and it's designed to take people from
a very basic level at the beginning
but it's designed in a way that you have
the tools and you have the support to
take you through each week of the
program and each course within the
program
you you build those skills and muscle
you know
work those muscles um
progressively to become stronger with
each course and that way
you're building towards
cumulative success
and
the
record of completion that we have is uh
we're very proud of so we're very proud
that Caltech shows us as a
simply learn as the delivery partner
yeah we have a part of that
values we were speaking we actually have
gotten a lot of questions in the given
as well uh so meanwhile folks who have
joined a little late just to let you
know if you're putting on your questions
in the chat box we might miss it because
we get a lot of messages on the chat box
so you can see a q a pop-up on your
laptop or your mobile wherever you
joined from you can just put down your
question there we'll be taking it
towards the end of the session or even
if you get the time so yeah just to let
you know
yeah so uh and at the end of it all we
the Celtic CDMA boot camp certificate is
something you'll be getting uh once you
complete uh this boot camp and uh also
core relative course certificates as
well uh you'll be getting up to 20 22
CEOs that is equal to 220 hours of
learning right that's pretty interesting
right and uh you'll be getting a caltex
ctma circle membership that means you
will be a part of a really cool Caltech
Alumni club uh Circle and uh this way
you will get to interact with a lot of
folks from around the world so that is a
really cool Circle to be in you know in
the category alumni Circle and also the
recognition at an online convocation so
you will be having a conversation online
that means not just you and your family
your relatives can also attend your
convocation which really happens right
in the offline offline session uh so
that's really that's really interesting
uh and uh you can let your friends
relatives everyone join yeah just to
clarify the CEUs represent I think one
ceu represents about 10 hours of
instruction these are the standardized
units that uh
used in industry in regular regulatory
bodies to prove that you have continuing
education for licensing or for other
requirements and so 22 CEUs represents
about
220 hours of work so
it's a good representation
um
caltex
I'm going to talk a little bit about
Caltech just because I've worked
with people from you know the Caltech
ctme with Mike Ash and
with uh
Rick Hefner over these last several
years and Caltech is a
Institute the California Institute of
Technology been around for 130 years
for those of you curious it is not part
of the University of California system
it is not part of the California State
University system privately run and
um it focuses on graduate education as
well as research so I see that we have
uh
Navia who is looking to go to Caltech as
an undergraduate
um Caltech admits very few
undergraduates said Navia go for it and
and uh if you get into
Caltech as an undergraduate that is a
really prestigious rare achievement
um
but they
mainly focus on people studying for
dance degrees they also have a number of
labs things like the
jet propulsion laboratory for NASA where
the
space probes and satellites that are
launched for science experiments run by
NASA
are developed designed and built at
Caltech and been sent off to be launched
so it's a really amazing place if you're
familiar
with the Big Bang Theory television
program the reason they chose Caltech is
because they wanted to do a show about
the funny idiosyncrasies of very
brilliant people and Caltech is where
you find
biggest concentration of very brilliant
people in the world
one of the top five universities
worldwide over
many years of evaluations and
the name Caltech on your resume is going
to be noticed
oh that's that's a lot like that pretty
interesting that's a really cool
University to get into
it and also now getting into the
eligibility and websites uh so for this
I can see that we need a bad experience
and knowledge of mathematics and
programming so what would you say for
folks who actually don't have that
knowledge in mathematics and programming
would they know would they not be able
to succeed uh if they take up this
particular program so what you would
want to do if you
if you are coming from a background you
have no mathematics background no
programming background and you are
fascinated by this this area it would
love to get into it you would want to
start by taking
um separate courses um
simply learn for example offers
courses in
basic concepts of programming and you
don't need much of that in order to get
the
Basics that you would need to succeed in
this Caltech program
um you do want to have
mentioned before the kind of mathematics
base that you would get from
the 10th grade 11th grade math
um so
that's maybe a little bit harder to do
independently but you'd wanted to to
make sure that you fill those
foundational requirements before you
started this program because there will
be
math there will be
training and programming here and
we do want to make sure that you are
ready for success and complete this
program
um don't get frustrated by
material
being above your your background so I
would say yeah you do want to have that
preparation beforehand and if you don't
we want to get it before you enroll in
this program
uh I can see we have we are actually
getting a lot of questions uh about the
program see so we'll be sharing that
yeah in a few few uh sometimes and uh so
meanwhile let's talk about the uh
program and basically how it prepares
you
yeah before we move from this slide we
do talk about work experience and you
don't have to have a college degree high
school diploma you have to have work
experience when and when we say work
experience that's not
you have to have experience working as a
programmer or
technical field
any work experience it's just a matter
of understanding how organizations
might use uh data and might use machine
learning
so having a network experience gives you
a better reference points for what
you're learning so that's why we
recommend it but it's not mandatory
but yeah
how the program prepares you and
we will be um
sharing with you what the the folks said
in our earlier session the tour of the
money management system
but before we get to that
let's talk about how the
program is constructed
uh so uh so this program basically
builds your AIML skills step by step I
can see someone who's actually asking
that on the chat as well can you give us
a you know program review like step by
step so I think this will be really
helpful if Stuart you can take us
through the steps uh towards this uh you
know program
so the the the first thing is an
induction session orientation session
which uh is an online couple of hour
session takes you through the um
uh how the program works in terms of
learning management system itself what
your curriculum will be where you're
going to find all the resources how to
get enrolled in in attend your live
classes and how to use the Virtual Lab
environment all of that so that you're
ready to start
as soon as the classes start and then
the first first module of the program
introduction to artificial intelligence
what what is
the
The General
idea of machines that can learn and that
can
simulate human thinking and
the that gives you an overview it gives
you some
basic orientation to the
subject matter takes you through some
basic exercises
then you move into a learning python in
more depth so that you have that tool
available for the rest of the course and
you learn about python scripting
language in the libraries that are used
for
mathematics and data manipulation data
presentation
then on into machine learning
and here's where you
learn the different methodologies
different approaches uh
says supervised learning unsupervised
learning that type of thing and then
uh you you in that module do a number of
exercises and projects to
get familiar with how to apply those
different techniques
start then moving into more
Advanced topics so you start learning
about the Keras and tensorflow tools
that are based on Python and but you
build neural network type deep learning
applications
um the last module takes you deeper into
advanced topics about Machine Vision
other aspects of deep learning and this
is where you get exposed for example to
some of the generative AI content
and then finally the Capstone project
this is a place where
now that you've gone through all of
these you've done projects all along the
way you've built a set of skills step by
step
your caption project is a chance for you
to take all of that new Knowledge and
Skills that and apply it to an
industry-based problem
so that you can demonstrate this is how
I took this problem analyzed it designed
the solution and built the solution
independently and that becomes part of
your uh portfolio something that you can
show off to Future employers
um
so that's the core of the program this
is what you need to do in order to earn
the certificate once you complete the
Capstone project successfully it's
evaluated
and if it's accepted then you get your
certificate
along the way you have the ability to
take electives
as electives that means they're not
mandatory but they are included in the
price of the program so you can take as
many or as few as you wish
we always recommend taking all of the
master classes because these are
opportunities
where Caltech professors Caltech
instructors and Industry experts come in
and speak uh
virtually or come in to your class and
speak to you for a couple of hours on a
monthly basis and take you into advanced
topics interesting new developments in
the field interesting new applications
and so this is a a really great way to
get oriented toward the industry in the
application area then uh real the other
uh electives uh take you deeper into
statistics if you need more of
background in statistics and haven't
need more depth or training there uh and
also the the
areas of NLP and speech recognition for
language
and reinforcement learning so these are
all
uh uh like I said available to you at
your discretion
there are ways for you basically to
self-customize this program for you
well thank you so much for taking us
through the steps oh for this program
which basically I've been doing it Miss
because uh I think let's move on to the
next one
sure
I can see go ahead yeah I can see that
there are a lot of tools and platforms
you will learn through this boot camp
but again I I'm pretty sure what we see
on this like there are much much more
tools and platforms we'll be going
through in this particular area with
more than by category yeah tell us more
about that we could only put a sampling
of what what's available but uh you
you're going to when we say you're going
to learn these things it means that
you're going to use them you're going to
be required to build projects with them
so it's not a matter of oh I I heard
about what this is and uh I've sorry
I've seen the manual
um this is really uh you'll be able to
say when you put these skills on your
resume that you have proof examples that
you can show in your digital portfolio
so
um
Python and the various libraries that
plot live and uh
those are the kind of basic tools you'll
learn as I mentioned Keras and
tensorflow take you into
deep learning and neural network type of
Arrangements uh
sklearn scikit-learn is uh the AI
applications platform
opencv for Machine Vision
um
nltv for natural language processing so
all of these
are tools that you will be presented
with trained on and have to use in
different aspects of the program
so uh when you come out of the program
you will be able to claim these uh on
your resume with proof examples
that's very powerful
that is definitely like having these
tools and platforms and many more to be
added to your resume after this boot
camp will definitely boost your profile
I think uh you have talked about the
Capstone project in that step by step
you know uh like likes pointers but uh
can you tell us like for folks who might
not have idea about a Capstone project
and what is its value after you have the
review CV and how it increases your
chances in you know Landing the dream
job in AIM uh can you tell us more about
that yeah Capstone comes from
architecture when you're building an
arch you put the last stone at the very
top that holds everything together and
it's called the Capstone
and so the last step the step that holds
everything together and in this case
what you're being presented with choices
of different projects that you can work
on
um pick one that interests you in
give an industry domain or or type of
application that interests you
you get to spend three to four weeks
working on the project
during the entire course the boot camp
you'll have been building up and doing
course projects that give you
tools and components that you can
assemble into your Capstone so it's not
doing it from scratch it's building on
everything you've learned
um you do this you meet weekly with your
instructor to make sure that you aren't
stuck on anything falling down any
rabbit holes
running into any walls
and at the end of the process you submit
the project and it's evaluated
and it becomes part of your
your uh your permanent record if you
will it becomes part of your portfolio
that you can then
if you're asked by an employer what's
your experience
I see you haven't had a job in this
region so what's your experience with
the technology you can pull out this
Capstone project and say here's the
problem definition I was asked to solve
this is how I approach the problem
design my solution implemented it and
that
is a demonstration-proof statement
that you understand
how to apply these skills and these
Technologies
to real world problems that that
employer might give you so that's the
power of the Capstone project
awesome thank you uh for the years to
the caption projects how easily you know
folks can showcase to their future
replies also we have industrial input
projects for other portfolios as well I
can say social media e-commerce
manufacturing and Tech Healthcare uh can
you take us through these projects
I won't go into detail about the
projects themselves but you can see that
in these to these projects you're asked
to take a a tool or a concept and apply
it to the kind of problem you'd find in
the real world right
uh
build a uh kind of mini replica of how
Amazon says people who bought this also
bought that or if you like this thing on
Netflix you might want to watch this
so these recommendation systems uh
sometimes they're sophisticated they're
not simply just saying well we're going
to look at
averages of who bought what especially
in
enter I'm sorry
especially in the entertainment industry
uh
it's not really clear why you would want
to watch
this other movie if you watch this movie
um sometimes the recommendations look a
little odd but there's some science
behind them so this is where you get to
go behind that curtain and build the
tool so some of these projects you will
do at the end of each
course within the program or some of
these projects might be your Capstone
um and again
said you don't have to
do the e-commerce project if what you
really uh want to do is get into
Healthcare AI
so you can pick that domain instead and
this is a great thing about course end
projects
typically in the program there's more
than one to choose from as well so you
get a lot of build your own adventure
aspect to this
so this is where we can take you through
the demo of the learning environment I'm
going to hope that this works properly
if you bear with me
I am going to
share this
meanwhile value sharing your screen now
store just to let folks know that uh
you've gotten a lot of questions in the
Q a box and folks who have not asked
their questions queries related to the
program please and go and add it to the
Q menu box we'll be taking that in some
time so yeah don't worry about that okay
so
this is a
where I'm a teacher uh Kumar who is one
of our senior instructors in AIML took
us through the
okay so our elements that you you will
get the access for now once you log in
different programs are there and we're
going to talk about Caltech AML bootcamp
is what we are talking about so once you
have that access to given to you you can
go to the program and this is
a pretty nice LMS in terms of its quite
comprehensive so first of all it gives
you uh track of how much course you have
covered already and how much is spending
so that you can keep a track of it and
you will know how far you have to go in
terms of completing the course and then
it starts with the all different
sections that we have covered I have
explained to you earlier so course one
is your orientation that I explained to
you then course 2 is Introduction to
artificial intelligence python for data
science apply data science with python
and so on and then eventually Capstone
project so this this all will be listed
over here
and then once you click on any of the
course like I am going to machine
learning now I have already completed
rest of it so I click on this so you get
this particular section over here where
where first of all you get a self
learning section over here once you
click on it it gives you
a bunch of videos over here which is
just for yourself learning purpose it's
not something which you have to do it
mandatorily it is something which is
there for your health purpose so you can
actually go through uh some of the
sessions over here like course
introduction is there probably a demo on
the on the Jupiter lab sometimes you
also get some explanation of the topic
this is just for your health purpose and
you can you can read that and you can
come to the classroom uh with with some
kind of understanding of it then once
you have your live classes it will be it
can be accessed over here so you can
click on the live class and it will give
you the list of all the classes that
you're enrolled for so it will say my
classes and you'll get the datewise
description over here past classes will
come and then once the session is over
suppose you want to go back to certain
Concepts that has been dealt in the
classroom so you want to watch the
recordings those recordings will also
will be available over here in the same
page and you can re-watch it whenever
you want
then
uh you also have an assessment page over
here if you see so this is this is where
uh once you finish your this particular
course uh some problem have been given
like if you see here it talks about
mercedes-bench Greener manufacturing uh
project then income qualification which
is from World Bank Healthcare book
rental recommendation so these are the
projects which has been given to you and
you're supposed to solve one of them in
order to get your certificate done for
this particular course which is machine
learning so if you actually look at it
you are given
some options over here which one
whichever you want to choose you can
choose and uh
and in the classroom when you are
working with a trainer so trainers will
be using some some PowerPoint
presentation or probably some PDFs and
they will also be working on the data so
all that you can find under reference
material over here so you don't have to
go anywhere else everything is available
over here you can simply download the
eBooks from here which are the
presentations used in the classroom and
the code books and the data set which
will be used in the classroom some of
the data which is part of your project
that also is available over here you can
download it
one more thing to add here once you go
to any project the project description
is there in terms of WhatsApp problem
statement and also what are the tasks
that you are supposed to carry out so
this is all given over here
now when you're working on when you're
going through the live sessions uh one
thing we told you that it's a Hands-On
session so the lab also is integrated in
your
LMS itself you don't have to download
anything on your system simply through a
browser you can access the lab and you
can start using it whenever you are your
trainer is asking you to do so this lab
looks like this uh you will have your
notebooks which you can upload over here
and you can work with that like in this
example I'm giving you a little
understanding of the lab I'm talking
about a analysis called regression which
is taught to you under machine learning
and under this analysis this is what
will be taught to you entirely so you'll
have a use case and then you'll have
different concepts covered over here
this is the entire regression analysis
done over here with different concepts
so we tell you what's the agenda then we
take a problem statement that this is
where the problem statement is and we
have been given a data and the idea is
to understand regression and apply on
this particular data to solar particular
problem so then the notebook will
consist of the code section as well
which will be given to you in advance
you can simply run with the trainer and
the trainer will explain each line
entirely what it's doing and why we are
writing and how we are running it
so then we'll load the data we'll
explain you what we are doing over here
entirely these codes will be available
to you suppose I make some changes in
the code book I write my own code
something that you have asked for some
clarification you needed or something
you wanted me to Simply run on the data
and show it to you so I'll run it over
here I'll add my piece of code over here
and then after the session ends I will
share this code book with you how do I
share I'll explain in this in in a bit
then we'll finish this entire
detailed uh uh Notebook on the
regression analysis how it works and
what kind of conclusion you can draw
different concepts will be covered over
here and as I mentioned this notebook
will be available to you in the LMS
itself or it will be shared post the
session in case if I make some changes
to it and then if I'm sharing the
I'm sharing the code book I can share
here on the community so this community
is pretty useful now here not only I can
share all the files or relevant uh
reading material with you I can also
interact with you like if suppose
weekends I'm taking sessions and
weekdays you are studying and you need
some help from any of the trainer
probably you want to interact with the
fellow Learners you can log into
community and you can
access to the the code files that I have
been sharing also you can interact with
the other Learners so that if you have
some doubt you can clarify in case if
some kind of technical issue happens you
need some help so there is a help
section over here which is available
24x7 you can simply click on that and
the help will be on your way
and once you finish everything then you
go to your certificate section it will
get unlocked you can download it and
keep it with you
that's how the LMS works and just to add
or summarize the entire thing this is a
pretty comprehensive LMS so at one place
you get everything you don't have to
download any of the components
separately everything is here the data
part the lab part problem statements the
code book The presentations everything
is in another one single
umbrella you can simply use it so that's
how LMS works and this is a small demo
on that
I hope that was helpful
that was uh
run through of our
learning management system I'll get back
to our presentation here
so
what I'm a teacher showed you is how you
can manage your curriculum what the live
virtual
classroom environment looks like the
tests the assessments
labs and projects Capstone project is
one of the modules within that
curriculum
showed you how the system keeps track of
your progress unlocks the certificate
for each of the course modules but it
also has the ability to remind you about
when things are due and
keep you on track so that's one of the
aspects of helping you succeed and
support tools like the help desk and the
Russia you're back with us
uh yes yes to it so yeah we also have
like global leaders as program advisors
Rick Hefner being one of them uh who is
the executive director of caltex ctme
and he has over 40 years of experience
in system development and basically uh
you know being one of the global leaders
he actually makes shows that simply
learn is delivering that value to you as
per the standards they have set so yeah
yeah that's that's important because
Caltech ctme is the part of Caltech that
you know companies and organizations
came to Caltech and said you have all
this marvelous technology and advanced
knowledge and
we would love to have our staff our
employees be able to do that type of
thing so Caltech formed the center for
technology and management education
and Rick is the executive director and
he makes sure that what simplylearn does
meets the standards of Caltech so that
they can put their name on that
certificate
talk about learner outcomes
go ahead you're good you're good uh
uh so I was just going to say the people
who come into this some of them uh again
in the boot camp you can come right out
of high school you don't have to have
work experience
but as we noted with the the first poll
we did a lot of the people in this
audience today are people with work
experience and you come from a lot of
different backgrounds well
that's typical of each cohort batch of
students that enrolls in this program
and so you may be learning alongside
people from
the Aerospace from Bank banking and
finance from
e-commerce from Healthcare uh and this
is a really great aspect of the live
interaction within the program because
you get not only to interact with your
instructor but with your fellow students
care
how things are used in different
Industries and it's a great networking
tool as well but you see
this is not strictly for uh
technology
Industries and technology companies this
is uh technology this is a particular
area the particular set of tools that
are applied
All Around the World in all different
Industries
Russia tell about some of these success
stories here
yeah so uh we can see who actually uh
started building his own models from
organizing and selecting the data to run
and testing the models through this
bootcamp and uh we can see one of the
Learners shalindra Kumar who actually uh
you know uh emphasizes on that the
instructor actually took many things to
advance this highly technical course and
answered all the students with their
queries they had which basically you
know made them more confident about the
aim and boot camp uh career so and we
can see Chris as well who actually uh I
guess he is up killing his way even even
during uh in this tenure and uh also
through this boot camp is looking
forward to have more opportunities to
work through his boot camp
and you can see a number more of
additional
um testimonials like this at the course
page we'll share that with the URL with
you soon but uh
uh we would love to to add you as one of
the people
in this
this assortment here so
um
Russia can you tell about the
career assist program
uh so yeah so uh basically through this
career assist program uh we actually
give you free access to expert webinars
and also career events by industry
leaders you also get to work on real
world projects across Industries and
create an amazing portfolio for of
projects also you get job assist
Services uh we have a collaboration with
Talent Inc uh which basically starts um
a poster once you've connected The
Bootcamp and is valid for six months
also a few Services provided by the job
versus Services by talenting you're
getting access to the job portal uh
resume rabbit and also you get your
resume review and rewrite Service as
well
um and also you get a one-on-one
interview Service uh which is with the
top interview which basically uh you
anyways are preparing right once you've
completed the boot camp you want to
prepare for an interview and that is
gives you give a good boost of
confidence uh through this uh you know a
job assist program
foreign
thank you
yeah and enrollment and program schedule
I think a lot of people have been asking
about the program fee uh so the program
fee for the static eiml bootcamp is
9999 and uh you if we have even
financing options available as low as
880 per month uh so we actually have
limited seats per cohort uh we only take
25 to 30 students per cohort in order to
you know uh pay attention to each and
every student by the instructor and you
can also ask your employer about a
tuition fee a reimbursement as well if
that is something that works with your
employer do check it out and if you have
any questions you can always reach out
to us at ask us at simplylearn.net
I said no uh if you would like to enroll
in the program you can select the option
yes
and submit it so this is like a very
quick poll
before we go towards reading the Q a
questions uh we have gotten plenty of
questions on the Q a so we'll we'll
definitely Mean Time For That Stuart so
meanwhile folks are voting in right and
I think we can close the poll in just
about two seconds here just hit that
submit button if you haven't and I will
close the poll
here are the results
about three quarters of our audience are
interested in getting started with the
program so I'm going to share
a little bit about that as well
talk about the enrollment steps
oops sorry
here we go
yeah so the enrolled steps include uh we
can see the enrollment and program
schedule here the next cohort which
starts at August 21st uh and the classes
will start at August 21st itself you
will have an induction in August 21st uh
there are three simple steps you just
need to follow you can just submit an
application and the application will go
for a review and you will get the
admission based on that and if you have
any questions you can still ask us at
simply run.net you can mail us there
yeah that's where you would send in your
application
so start with that
quick uh quick question for those of you
who said you were interested how soon do
you think you'll start
yeah you can see a pop-up menu screen
like if you plan on enrolling into the
course or you're still thinking about it
so how soon do you plan to enroll this
will make us understand you know like
what exactly are you looking for what is
the timeline you're looking for so you
can see the first option immediately if
you are planning to join immediately
within three months within six months
more than six months from now so you can
choose an option which you're
comfortable with
and I'm going to close the poll now
because it's a pretty straightforward
question so here we go
and here's the result
yeah we can see the result uh we can see
most of the folks actually want to join
immediately that's great and we can see
a few of the folks uh want to join
within three months uh and the very few
of the folks are looking within six
months or more than six months from now
so that's great get getting to know you
know what exactly you're looking for in
terms of timeline yeah two-thirds of the
audience wants to start uh sometime
later you know in the fall here so
whether that's August whether that's
September or October so
pretty impressive
so now we can take the questions and
answers
sure
and
I think maybe what I'll do is stop
sharing so that you don't have to stare
at the slide the whole time but
um
what kinds of questions do we have
so uh that yeah the thing is to it it's
actually not visible to me right now I'm
sorry I've got I've got it here no
problem you know that you had a issue
with your laptop so
um
I actually wrote a few questions down
from the chat as well yeah uh like Kelly
has asked like do I need programming
skills to join the boot camp uh my
background is is in Business School
yeah you need you need to have some
understanding of programming
um so if you've been in business school
and you've been using Excel
and you have some idea of how functions
work and that type of thing and
especially if you built any macros that
that gives you some Basics but you
probably would like to um
maybe do uh look at simply learn uh
website and see if there's a kind of a
introduction to programming Concepts
free course that you can take
and that's really
going to give you the background
combined with with what you your work
experience is uh we're looking at a
question in Q a
I know classes or online live classes
and all mentors and teachers from the
USA
um so for the boot camp uh the Caltech
boot camp
we heavily
staff it with instructors from the US
amatindra is one of the instructors for
the version of the Caltech program for
India rest of the world
but the the content of the course is is
similar in each case
um
aiml's posted as a boot camp
uh
devopsis posted postgraduate program in
the cert there are different programs
um Peter the the Caltech uh simply
learning programs are
loaded as boot camps generally speaking
in the U.S however
um and there showed us postgraduate
programs for India rest of the world
uh devops is an exception because
there's just the one worldwide program
called postgraduate program and devops
so
do I teach any classes no I I do not at
present teach any of the classes uh
uh
uh there is
we will be sending a link to this
recording to people so I know that
doesn't help people who have left
already it will help them but it doesn't
help the city state it because they're
not here to hear it but they will get
the recording
um
is the course instructor supportive of
using chat GPT to generate the python
code that's required no
um uh you would have to ask the
instructors
specifically for that course or for that
module if they would accept that but
generally speaking
um they want you to do the Hands-On work
so that you understand uh what it is
that's behind the code
rather than taking a shortcut to begin
with they do want you to start with that
because then you'll understand
when you do go into a working
environment and you
chat GPT or other types of generative
tools
to create code
you will then be able to assess the
quality of the code that's generated
you'll be able to look through it and
you'll be able to say okay
that does what I asked it to do or
you'll be able to say no I have to tweak
it
so without without that experience uh
would be relying blindly on the machine
and again as we said
purpose of AI at ml is extend your
capabilities not to replace them
um are you do we offer the boot camps
accessible to high school students
unfortunately do have to be 18 years old
so uh
truti you do have to wait that one extra
year
apologize for that don't know when your
birthday is but
ask your parents for this as a birthday
present
um I think
skill required for AI
chartered engineer how to use AI for
evaluation land Building platform
machine reviews
David that is a great question
um so
AI can be used in
lots of different aspects where
different factors that are historically
are traditionally used
yet can be considered for things like
valuation
um so
you would start to to explore the
problem by looking at different
sets of data that are available that you
haven't been using them
the reason you hadn't used them
previously is because
they didn't seem to add a lot of value
and they're a lot of work but when you
start looking at using AI or machine
learning those sources suddenly the the
small amount of value they add can add
up and and the Machine can take
advantage of it without creating more
work for you so
um
this is a kind of a rich area for
developing new models take into account
other factors about the the
characteristics of the
location the land the buildings the
equipment that is a a really great area
for it
um
my company is doing AI Transformations
can I bring a case as a project for the
classes yes the number of the
instructors will allow you to bring in
cases from your real work
um so that's a great question
um
is live stream lecture attendance
mandatory
some of the live stream lecture
attendance is mandatory some of the
courses you are allowed to substitute
the
self-paced learning for some of the live
classes but in general for each of the
courses you can see in order to earn the
certificate you must complete and it
will tell you what you have to do so
usually that requires attending 85
percent of the live
classes and um so it's very important
and the system will keep track of your
attendance
um and so
you want to come into this program
understanding that
want to be available for as many of the
weekends as possible for that six months
there are
class recordings so that you can catch
up if you do happen to miss something or
if you want to review the material
and
to always recognize that you can't be
there for every single weekend every
single time so
it's not a hundred percent attendance
mandatory but
you should plan on attending as many of
those as possible because you get much
more value
from the interaction the 22 CEUs as I
mentioned before
standardized measurement of continuing
education if you are unfamiliar with
them that probably means you're in a job
or a business or a position where you
don't need them so you shouldn't be as
concerned but if you do know what they
mean then you know that you have to earn
a certain number of CEUs in your field
every year in order to keep your
licensing or your qualifications so
uh Peter
my company reimburses based on a grade
receipt pass fail or letter grade
can you receive incremental billing and
grade updates
um that is an interesting question Peter
I'm not sure how it would be set up
however I do know that you can receive
um
installment payment
which is not quite the same as
incremental billing
um but in Solomon payment and yes you
will get great updates during the
program because each course you complete
comes with a certificate of completion
for that module of the boot camp so as
you complete for example the
introduction to AI module you will get a
certificate that says I've completed
that module then you'll do machine
learning from uh python for data science
and machine learning
you'll get a certificate for that module
so you'll be able to accommodate that
requirement
does it devil asks is it live or
pre-recorded you have live sessions in
almost all the classes live sessions
pretty much every week
um four hours on Saturday four hours and
Sunday
um
you do have pre-recorded videos that you
can use to get prepared for the classes
or to review the material
and as I said other than the class
sessions of eight hours a week
want to be able to put in about 10 or so
hours of time in between to study the
material do the projects
um
let's move down
because sending the application involve
any fee no you don't pay the fee until
the application is accepted
the application process may include an
assessment test where the we'll send you
a brief test that you need to do online
to show your level of knowledge about
math and
programming skills
um again it's not up to it's not a very
intensive
um
like college graduation testers
just a brief assessment to show what
level you're at
um
what is the major difference between
this boot camp and the unit science PG
so the AIML bootcamp has certain
Concepts from data science but it
focuses
more intensely on machine learning and
on the Technologies behind machine
learning the data science PG focuses
more on the broader aspects of the use
of data to solve problems which may
include AI techniques there's a module
in there about using AI but it doesn't
go into the
detail or
study of these Advanced topics is The
eiml Bootcamp does it does however talk
about more aspects of what can you do
with data what is the what are the
classes of problems that can be solved
with data and what techniques would you
use to solve those problems so the AIML
is more focused it's more application
focused then the data science one
uh what are the typical outcomes in job
placements and salaries I would suggest
you ask the email ask us at
simplylearn.net because they do have
those statistics help you with that
um
you have a little bit of problem to
learn Indian English
boot camps
Caltech boot camps which are targeted
towards uh North American audience
primarily are taught primarily Again by
U.S instructors
and the times for the live sessions on
the weekends generally are around
7 A.M or 8 A.M on the West Coast
for four hours there are from about 11
A.M or 12 noon start on the East Coast
and so they're designed so that you can
kind of do your day and have the rest of
your day to work on or to free to
for your own
life to continue
uh
and
if you happen to be visiting from
another part of the world and you want
to enroll in one of the programs that's
targeted towards uh rest of the world
the class times are different so that
they're more compatible with scheduling
those that's one of the reasons why
we've divided the two areas
um
those are all the questions I see do you
see any other ones from the chat that
you wanted to take
uh yeah so we have gotten like uh one
question from azim uh what all
qualifications are required for an EA
engineer and which companies hire with
such profile
so yeah yeah if you go on to any of the
job boards
The Glassdoor dice
any of them
and you type in AI engineer or ml
engineer or ml developer
you'll see that the
fantastic range of jobs and companies
that are hiring so we put a kind of a
sampling on one of those slides about
companies in various areas but the
numbers so vast
variety is so wide that it's impossible
to
include all of that but you can take a
look on those things and see a lot of
great opportunities and and they're
across so many different Industries
because Ai and ml are being used in so
many different ways
oh yeah and uh like one more one last
question I don't have advanced python
experience uh which is the only concern
for enrollment as I am still learning
python uh do you suggest to wait until I
master python no you don't need to wait
till you master python you'll be
covering python skills in the boot camp
so
um if you have
the fact that you are studying Python
language now means you probably have
more than enough background to start the
boot camp because and the boot camp will
probably take you to the level of python
understanding that you want to have
so um
yeah you don't have to view that as a
barrier you're you're already well past
that
okay I think we'll take one last
question from Robert too either if you
have not taken it already uh so have you
taken it already so uh is The Bootcamp
designed to be no one left behind uh
with the backtracking to accommodate
seniors I'm a very interested uh 72 year
old the term sounds intimidating yeah
one of the people who have this color
beard right
um
the point is it
it is
it is designed principle to be nobody
left behind because what happens is you
have the opportunity to ask questions in
the classes
um you have the opportunity to
self-study you have the opportunity to
contact your instructor during office
hours and you can get some one-on-one
help you have the opportunity to go onto
the community and host a thread and ask
your fellow students or other
instructors to to chime in on what
you're concerned with
um and
so a lot of opportunities a lot of of
support
system itself will keep track of your
progress it'll send you prompts and
reminders
um so it's
we we can't claim that a hundred percent
of the enrollees complete the course but
we do have a very high percentage and
you can ask a learning Consultants about
that and it's uh we're extremely proud
of that it's an industry-leading member
um when online education started the
number of people who actually completed
online courses because they were not
interactive because they didn't have
these features the numbers were very
poor and now the numbers are comparable
with live
traditional learning
people drop out of
traditional colleges
um
at similar rates
so so
this is this is definitely a great way
to learn
a great way to have the confidence that
somebody will be behind you helping you
succeed
awesome thank you so much Stuart uh I
think we'll just take one last question
like what are the next couple cohort
start dates Beyond August 21st are you
able to share the name of the leading
sector before I sign up for a go uh just
to let them know like 11 September is
the next cohort uh about the lead
instructor can you help us with that
store uh you can get
um from the syllabus I think if you
download it you can see some of the
instructor names but you can also ask
the the learning Consultants to the
instructor faculty are for your program
um generally these courses are taught
not by professors they're taught art in
our training boot camps they're taught
by industry practitioners
so people who have been doing this for a
number of years who can tell you what
the real world applications are and how
to do these things in the real world
um not just from an academic standpoint
a big Advantage because our our Caltech
ctme itself and and simply learn in
general is uh we're both oriented
towards helping people with practical
skills for career development so
we focus in on how you would use this uh
in the real world
in a job
yeah I think that answers all of the
questions we have gotten so far in the Q
a and you have taken the few ones from
the chat as well uh thank you so much
Stuart for helping us out uh with the
program over you uh I'll go back to the
last couple of yeah
I've put into the chat the
uh email address for ask us at
simplylearn.net and I've also put into
the chat the
URL for our program page
yeah I just share it once more sure
because we're getting a lot of messages
on our chat
so
yeah the last last question for our
audiences uh if you're interested in
getting started would you like us to
have a learning consultant contact you
right away
yes
for the folks who have uh like uh
selected the option yes uh like do you
want to enroll in this program uh for
sure go go for the yes option because
obviously they will need assistance
right like they would want to go through
the program in much more detail before
they take it out so yeah
to
you can contact us through ask us at
simplylearn.net to get started you can
also from the program page uh you can
contact us through that direction to get
started uh wanted a shortcut of having
us call you and get you started here
and I'm going to show you
about half of the people who responded
said yes so
yeah I'm just sharing the link One Last
Time on the chat here
bootcamp by Caltech
Russia it's been a pleasure uh
participating in this webinar with you
thank you for being such a gracious host
uh likewise Stewart uh it's it's a
pleasure to host you actually in your
last webinar and thank you so much for
you know hosting these amazing webinars
with simply learn and I'm pretty sure
I'm pretty sure we'll get to see you uh
someday as a surprise guest or you know
as a leading speaker or or just just
just casually you know so we will
definitely would want to uh you know
catch up with you here as well and the
audience is the audience has been lovely
I must say right well yeah I want to
thank everybody in the audience for
taking the time out of their day to join
us and learn about
the opportunities in Ai and ml
so we'd love to see you in the program
thank you again
thank you so much folks thank you thank
you Steward again okay that concludes
the webinar
yes
thank you so much everyone for joining
and thank you for being a great audience
thank you so much folks we'll be ending
the webinar now uh there are many more
such webinars lined up you can go and
check out in the simply learn events uh
webinar section uh so thank you so much
have a good evening good morning good
afternoon wherever you're logging from